it's great to be joined today by
attorney Mike Papantonio co-host of ring
of fire radio PAP DuPont and it's
spin-off company are going to be paying
921 million dollars to 3,500 plaintiffs
this is all about a toxic chemical known
as c8 which was used during the
manufacture of teflon many people know
teflon is that nonstick coating on
cooking implements how'd you first hear
about what was going on with c8 yeah
well my specialty is you probably know
David is to try cases I was brought in
as a trial lawyer to try the first first
three or four test cases before then it
had been worked up against completely
unbelievable odds the lawyers there in
the around the Ohio Valley did an
incredible job with no help from the
media no help from the government no
help from the DOJ at all they did it
single-handedly as a matter of fact
there was actually push back all along
the way by the government who simply
didn't want this story told the EPA had
really dropped the ball Department of
Justice as usual had done nothing to
investigate or prosecute the people who
were responsible so what ended up
happening is it was just a long slog
that's the best way I can I can describe
it in your research how far back was it
revealed that DuPont knew about the
health risks that were posed by c8 well
they knew about they knew about health
risks as early as the the mid 60s they
were performing tests on a lab animals
of every kind everything from monkeys
the beagles to rats and all of the tests
were bad all of the tests showed bad bad
health effects so they knew right off
the bat but by 1980s they were already
warning their own employees that c8
could cause cancer the problem was they
weren't telling the American public that
c8 could cause cancer they weren't
telling the people that were drinking
the c8 water every day that it would
cause it would cause cancer people
people were having to drink c8
contaminated water
were showering with it they were you
know preparing baby bottles with it they
were they used it every part of their
life it was it was a contamination level
that brought up the c8 blood
contamination in these people on
incredible amounts I mean
sometimes 50 times what it should have
been there should be no sea level c8 in
anybody's blood it's man-made it
shouldn't be there but it was all over
these people's lives as it is in a lot
of parts throughout this country a lot
of places in this country right here in
my hometown of Pensacola
they've got c8 in the drinking water
well it shouldn't be there it's man-made
as far as the distribution of the
plaintiffs some of some in our audience
probably know about how in Texas there
are those five-gallon office water
cooler water jugs like a thick plastic
there's pollution that comes from the
factories where those are produced that
is very very harmful to human health
carcinogenic and when you look at where
what towns are sort of mostly affected
by that pollution it's poor towns it's
disproportionately non-white towns what
kind of analysis can we make along those
lines to the 3,500 plaintiffs involved
here is there also a class story behind
it there absolutely as you hear what
happened was you had corporate America
move into the south they came in like
corporate like like corporate
carpetbaggers they knew people would
work for low wages they knew that people
wouldn't be concerned about the
environment if they were being paid
decent money because they had to make a
living they had to take care of their
family people were made willing to make
that trade-off you'd often hear here
claims you know no matter how bad the
pollution was in the South you'd always
hear some local saying well it smells
like money to me even though it was
pollution that was potentially killing
their children and so what ended up
happening was you'll find this air this
this area in the south this this Gulf
Coast area is the pollution is
extraordinary because all corporate
America knew they could come down here
pay low wages not worry about the
environment they could externalize all
of their poison all over the community
and then and then leave town when it was
all over so talk to us a little bit
about the trial I mean I'm always
fascinated
to here what case corporate defense
counsel attempts to make to distract or
reject the the allegations of liability
here what case did they try to make here
well the case was that they didn't know
in the it was how could we have known
well all they had to do is read through
documents I think the jury was moved by
the idea that every trial they would
hear the defendant stand up they'd hear
Dupont stand up in the beginning and say
gee we just didn't know if we would have
known this wouldn't happen and then
within 15 minutes in the trial they're
saying dozens and dozens of documents
that were hidden from the American
public hidden from the EPA where was
very clear that they did know in their
intent was to continue what they were
doing anyway for 50 years because they
were making so much profit on Teflon so
that's the defense and anytime you wage
a defense like that and then almost
immediately that defense is crushed by
the the documents themselves the
testimony themselves it's very very
tough to overcome
that's why juries punished on juries
felt that they showed a conscious
disregard for the health and safety of
people all along the Ohio River Valley
and so you know they got they were
getting ready to hit be hit in the
fourth trial for you know an
extraordinary amount of money but the
first trial started off with one of the
minor cases that by the way they picked
their this is the one they wanted to
test this is the one they wanted to try
and I think is 1.8 million second was
twelve point
excuse me 5.7 million third was twelve
point nine million something like that
so it just kept getting worse and worse
for them and they did what they should
have done which is to close this down
the reason it wasn't done soon enough is
because the media did not do their job
had the media done their job and told
the story that should have been told
this would have happened much sooner but
you have an American media that it that
they're ordered to do what they do by
their advertisers and if DuPont or Dow
Chemical who is getting ready to merge
with DuPont put pressure on the media
then they won't do their job we no
longer have a functional media this this
case this case is the best example of
David this case is a case that should
have gone away years ago
but the story would never be told on ABC
NBC CBS MSNBC none of the corporate
media because they simply don't do their
job
it is a worthless source of information
anymore sometimes when settlements like
this are reached there's sort of a line
in the sand Ron where there can be no
more plaintiffs or litigation going
forward is that the case here or can
there be more plaintiffs brought into
this know there's there's 70,000 people
affected by this this settlement only
has to do with about 3,000 people that
people are going to become ill as time
goes on this is this is the product that
is in their blood stays in their blood
David for 25 years it's in the
environment for 2 million years you
can't get rid of it if you can't get rid
of it anybody's blood you can't chelate
it you it's there it's going to stay
there for 25 years unfortunately as it
stays there the risk of thyroid disease
cancer just as dramatically increased
testicular cancer kidney cancer and and
so this this is what these people are
facing so going forward in this
settlement in though no lake precludes
people from being able to protect
themselves in the future well we've been
following it we're going to continue
following it we've been speaking with
attorney Mike Papantonio co-host of ring
a fire radio also host of America's
lawyer on RT always great to talk to you
thank you thank you